you talked about you know microbial life
kind of spreading right it could be like
a like a mold but it just little spores
and little bits could be spread out what
is that when you say that
microbial what is what is it actually
so it would be um those spores of
bacteria for instance
right so there's plenty of spores on
earth
uh of bacteria that can survive space
and hard radiation
bacillus there's a number of bacillus
strains that have this ability
so you know it's if it's you know frozen
and in vacuum and it could last an awful
long time and we already have instances
of bacteria and other living things
you know surviving hundreds of thousands
of years and then being resurrected
right so it's you know it's it's not a
big difference between 100 000 years and
say 10 million or even a billion years
the time that it might take to go from
one place to another
um
you know i mean imagine uh a large chunk
of rock
like what avi loeb
pointed out the umuma event
right uh going from one solar system to
another you know it just takes a little
bit of that
over time
uh to spread out into many different
places uh around the galaxy or even
around
you know the universe let's say but
there's some interesting evidence for it
uh and and
uh
one of those bits of evidence is
uh what's called the moore's law of uh
genetic complexity you've all heard of
moore's law
for semiconductors it's a
you know it's a made-up law but the idea
is that for whatever reason
um every i don't know what it is ten
years or five years whatever the number
is uh the complexity of computer chips
doubles
right and the speed doubles
um and so we're always as you'll see if
you read in the in computer magazines
there's this have we reached the end of
moore's law
you know and then somebody discovers
quantum computers
right uh and so then
etc so you know it's it's more just an
observation of what happens so somebody
thought to look at the complexity of dna
and the regulatory uh regions of dna
that are in many ways like a computer
right these are the areas upstream of
the
uh regions of the genes that encode the
proteins the things that you know we are
and the enzymes that make us etc there
are these regulatory regions which if
you're a computer scientist you would
look at and you would think of as the
is the actual code
of what's of what is of how a person is
made
um okay and now the complexity of that
in let's say simple
bacteria it's it's it's extremely simple
right there they don't have the kind of
regulatory phenomenon that that we have
um but if you think of bacteria as a
ancient
uh example of what our great great great
great grandparents might look like
right and then you look and you go up
the chain
of
um evolution from bacteria to eukaryotes
to multicellular
things etc up the chain and you call
those and you call that evolution
right that's all we really have to see
right now
um and then you look at and then you
basically say well bacteria evolved
i don't know uh two billion years ago
whatever the number is these other ones
this so you create that timeline and
then you give some measure of complexity
it turns out that the complexity
of when things actually
started
was about 10 billion years ago
billion or million billion billion
billion okay but how long has earth been
around
four billion years billion
right okay so there's a six billion year
gap
um so basically there's two answers to
that the first answer is it actually
evolved
that long ago
right right six billion years ago or
something about evolution took a fast
leap up
and then became the straight line
yeah i'm really curious about that up
part so so it's it's either if if life
on earth
happened and uh and instantiated only
four billion years ago
fast leap up and then became this
linear curve
and that's perfectly possible
um or you could say it started somewhere
else
and just traveled here right
okay
and so um that's the first one i find
that interesting
uh the second one is a paper
and and that actually is a paper and
then a peer-reviewed and there's another
peer-reviewed paper
called the wow signal in the genetic
code by a couple of mathematicians from
i think uzbekistan
and i don't pretend to understand the
math and i'm sure there's some
statisticians that would argue with it
but their concept was interesting
the
um
the com the actual what we call the
genetic code
the
the uh
transfer rnas that basically say
you know proline goes here or leucine
goes there that allow for the um
proteins to be made
they are so well organized
in terms of the structure of the of who
codes for what
um
that
it looks like it was designed
right and then they go through some
mathematical models
of why
it had to have been designed
and
you know there's some caveats that i'll
mention at the end here
uh
that uh the chance of it not having been
designed is like one in several hundred
trillion right right
and so what they're saying is the wow
message so you've heard of this thing
called the wow message that when
somebody first thought that they heard a
radio signal from another
civilization they said wow they wrote
wow on it and that became the wow signal
so they said look the signal is actually
in our dna
the fact that the dna was
planned
and organized is right there in front of
us that's the wow signal
now
you know there's um
there's a guy
who wrote uh a book called the selfish
gene
uh and um his name is richard dawkins a
famous professed genetics professor from
england
who basically says look that's
rubbish
not this wow signal itself but you know
the whole notion of
divine
intervention or
planned
genetics that you know the creationists
it's rubbish because there are other
mathematical principles that you can
throw at this that say that you don't
need that
you know and and i think this guy is
fantastic right so his is a fantastic
counter argument
to the wow signal
but it isn't the disproof
right same saying that there is an
alternate explanation
isn't proof of the alternate explanation
right it's like that's the it's so it's
still
in limbo
right as to what it whether this wow
signal is true
or not even if it's not true
the fact that the dna code is so
organized in and of itself is beautiful
i mean as a scientist i i i appreciate
the the beauty of that
right it's so well organized and i mean
but we can look at any ecosystem and say
it's so well organized somebody must
have invented it
no no you don't have to invent it
richard dawkins shows how things can
evolve so what about i mean this makes
me start thinking about
fractals and energy and patterns and
recurring patterns in nature
and
i mean do you
what about that what about just
patterns of energy
showing up
on a micro and a macro level
what about that well i mean yeah so
the universe is organized with
a pattern right if you look right down
at the laws that we think are running
the universe all of these particles
with features and capabilities
uh how they will interact
um
that allow for us
basically it says that embedded in the
structure of the universe is the
capability to produce us
now the question
the open question is did somebody create
the universe so that something like us
could
occur
right or is it just chance and we're
lucky
right so there's this concept in the
multiverse ideas of that the in other
universes the laws of physics might be
different
right that if you take the various what
we call constants
of physics planck constant etcetera is
all these you know various numbers and
you change them only slightly
uh any one of them only slightly
suddenly you don't have a universe like
ours that could even have
protons
right that it would basically you you
wouldn't get anything you would just
remain a big mist
could ever coalesce into anything
so there's this notion of what's called
the anthropic i think it's called the
anthropic principle
that
we only think of ourselves as the only
universe that is because the laws
are such that we can see ourselves
but in the other universes no one could
become and if you were to go there you
would basically just explode you know
you would just dissipate into nothing
right
right so so embedded in the laws of the
universe are the rules that allow for
evolution
it doesn't mean that they were
the universe was created for that it's
just that retrospectively it is that
there's a science fiction book that i
always remember a story
um about this thing that evolved in an
ocean on another planet and it in the
and it began with it could not remember
but could deduce its origins
right so we can't remember our origins
but we can deduce them
sure we can deduce the kinds of things
that must have happened
and then we can even go beyond that now
as i'm saying about the structure of the
universe to say that the structure of
the universe allows for atoms it allows
for molecules those molecules can come
together and if they can reproduce they
will that's the essence of the selfish
gene from richard dawkins is that if
given resources and you can reproduce
you will find a way to reproduce
right so you don't need to imagine a god
right that created you right but you
know it's it and and he goes through a
lot of very good arguments about it but
but so that's the kind of way that i i
think of it that it says that if we came
from a panspermic event
i'm not sure that's a word but just made
it up
then that means that there are other
potentially seeded planets elsewhere
most
also could have
right you know created civilizations
now and then if you go as far as saying
that um
there are other universes
exactly which have let's say different
timelines once you propose that another
universe can happen
and it might have a different timeline
than ours
it i mean it the time there's no such
thing as a common timeline at that point
you're independent
you can come from any point in another
universe's timeline and if you are
sufficiently advanced you might have
learned ways to jump
between universes
[Music]
you